something else that uh obviously uh you
speak about in your music uh yo talk
about because I think a lot of people
don't realize like the pimp and culture
in Memphis is like a big deal you know
what I'm saying
um that is like kind of like a side to
the to the
game uh obviously it is the game but
aside to the
streets that I don't think we hear about
are left anymore
because when I was a kid we had so many
artists like too short
just so many artists do or die you know
what I'm saying and and I don't you
don't hear about it as much anymore in
music
um how big uh is that culture in Memphis
still to this day like not to say you're
involved in Idaho Memphis no Memphis
time for making Easy Money pimping hoes
in style yeah I'm making Easy Money
pimping hoes it's serious you know what
I'm saying and like like I tell
everybody like that this conversation
come up like Memphis Memphis is in
Memphis Pippin is like selling weed
it's different breakage though like you
got you got [ __ ] who pimp Junkies
you got you know what I'm saying like
it's just different Breakers you got
[ __ ] who you know what I'm saying it's
just same [ __ ] it's people who sell
[ __ ] fat and all lace drugs
it's just in your it's just in your
blood who sell [ __ ] you got lame
[ __ ] you ain't even got to be a
gangster to be a pimp right you ain't
got to be a killer to be a pimp like you
could be a straight lame and dude you
got [ __ ] that ain't gone I ain't gone
bust a grape and Welch's yard like but
they pimping like right you know and I
tell you hey I'm like it's a non-contact
sport P like they don't want no problem
I want nothing to do with no smoke you
know what I'm saying but there's some
pipping so if the brackets are pimping
uh dope fiends what's the highest
bracket the ice breaker when you get up
incorporate like extortion and like if a
senator comes to town extortion it'll
get crazy I ain't gonna put out it out
there but it get crazy it's a darker
side to it like like if a private
investigator like needs a girl to set up
some rich guy
no take some crazy pictures like you
know you see it in the movies in that
Bingo now you barking up the right shoes
look I I need you to get this Senator
butt ass naked strapped to a [ __ ] bed
and uh I'm gonna have somebody across
them like porn stars your own porn
company like it get deep like it it get
a whole lot more people yo but when you
went in like only fans wasn't popping
right no so not only fans is like this
whole back page with popping Backpage
rest in peace
listen I'm a married man but I I am very
aware that Backpage is no longer a thing
first they got rid of Craigslist and
then Backpage with now the [ __ ] are
on only fans yeah I don't even know I
mean you still don't understand on the
fan
you know a lot of guys are like managing
women on only fans I have friends who do
it there's rappers who do it uh who were
we just talking to that manages girls
no not a little pump
tiger does it uh Adam 22 from no jumper
does it but I feel like it's kind of
like
I guess it's kind of like uh having your
own porn site but it's like it's like
you know instead of you get paid once
like 800 to shoot a scene
you get paid residual income off your
content so I think a lot of women
you know are I thought you were gonna
hit that [ __ ] are you I mean
this guy bring that thing over here
on camera
this
is a monster this is a [ __ ] this is a
finger oh my God a whole gorilla Frank
going up
oh
wait you cut it in half it okay okay
next you got a small fast
[ __ ]
yeah no but only fans man shout out to
only fans
you can get all the only fans content
for free on Reddit
that's neither here nor there
but he's yeah so in 2017 Backpage was
still a thing that's crazy I feel like
Backpage has been gone for like 10 years
yeah shout out to Backpage
when I was a kid there was a streak in
Phoenix Arizona called Van Buren
and it was uh like the main track right
so we would like
I was like 12 13 my cousin was 15 we
take my parents car and we used to ride
up and down Van Buren
[ __ ] with prostitutes
we'd like we would just troll them we
would throw water balloons at them all
kinds of [ __ ] but it was it's crazy we
got chased by a pimp once actually it's
oh yeah yeah because we we hit a chick
with a water balloon and uh and then we
got chased down by a dude in an Escalade
and we got away but it was it was pretty
[ __ ] it was crazy because now like
the internet just changed the whole [ __ ]
it's wild
um but yeah the world has changed since
you've gotten out um